Channel 8 news mourning the loss of a
former member of our own team after a
wrong way car crash over the weekend
thank you for joining us at four I'm
Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus
Nevada State Police also revealing today
the identity of the driver who allegedly
drove headfirst into his car on the
wrong side of the 215. it happened early
Sunday morning just south of Town Center
Drive Ryan
mowings us live
hack this tragedy has had a
handle yeah Kirsten Bryan not only did
this crash take the life of our former
co-worker now his wife remains in the
hospital in stable but critical
condition she was the passenger in his
car and has since undergone multiple
surgeries we're told but this crash far
beyond what longtime friends remember of
him while the Latin Community now
rallies around her recovery
sorry Carlos Gomez attempting to grasp
the tragedy of his close friends of two
decades 48-year-old Jose C Tabares and
his wife Jessica tabarez he was once in
eight news now sales employee while she
is president of a marketing company I
don't think but they load to dance going
there I started to have a character and
everything they're really good at it
Gomez is Vice President of the Latin
Chamber of Commerce where the couple was
considered family the past two days the
Latin Community grieving if I need
anything
is not related to or anything advice by
calling up and he always respond no
matter what day it is or what's gonna
the crash happened along the 215 Beltway
south of South Town Center Drive the
driver of a white Cadillac allegedly
entering the Northbound Lanes from the
south before crashing head on into the
car Jose was driving and Jessica was
passenger in Nevada State Police
identifying that driver as 39 year old
quiniana longier long she also died in
this crash the impact turned the cards
counterclockwise and hit another car
that sent two people to the hospital
when you are driving and you see the car
in front of you you don't you don't have
a chance to move what else you can do I
it's unbelievable
now it's unclear where this driver
entered the 215 but Nevada State Police
did receive calls of a driver traveling
the wrong way closer to the Charleston
area that was just about two minutes
before the crash itself and when we
tried asking Nevada State Police was
impairment potentially a factor as of
right now that currently remains unclear
reporting live over the 215 at South
Town Center Ryan Matthey 8 News Now